tu scène là
ça rime avec casse toi
sur ces 8 c'est comme aux as far west y
a pas de place pour deux personnes
aujourd'hui simba est en train de
bouffer mufasa au caire
attendait l'ex animateur at est un truc
à répondre comme ça ouais ça on est au
coup de pression bref
trembla nous
annonçant pas que ces motos fini
émission d'hier soir j'aurais pu le
faire animé par ma soeur
ne veut pas aller sur tf1 c'est pas faux
vois tu aurais pas abîmer une belle
gueule comme ça
aux actus puisse la toucher
ouais ben ali
[Applaudissements]
sa collègue à part dans son slip il
manque de rapidité
après une faible remontée sur appris à
côté dans ses à-côtés d'après côté april
on ne nous a jamais vu danser savais que
tu assistes une émission validé dans ce
média et coup de pression
tu as été bon merci marc houtch je pense
que dimanche matin à 9h unis fait
vraiment rigoler
[Rires]
dimanche on met attend pour de vrai
apens avec toi après une fois ce choix
mais ne renie pas six
mois au moins 650
sur la canéda 300 milles avec des
revenus de patrick sébastien ou même pas
du tout passé 6 conac a déjà regardé la
risée le maire basque il dit sur
montbard thuram essais des rowdies fils
de patrick marie toi tes frais donc ça
veut dire qu'on paye un loyer de
l'argent surtout aimé y ait des
habitudes à prendre on a mis de l'argent
sur wii j'entends hymne à la vie mais
c'est bien
tu fais moins de 650 parents de l'argent
c'est vrai qu'on peut aller chercher
champions et plus de 650 du coup c'est
moi qui prends la large
650 droit de revenir
est ce que dans vos têtes cyril vous
avez déjà imaginer que ce soit un fiasco
que les missions doivent s'arrêter et de
trouver un remplaçant pour le samedi
d'après alors j'ai déjà imaginer que ce
soit parce que oui
que ce soit en est un succès oui non
non non pour moi pour moi je n'ai je
suis très confiant oui je suis très
confiant pourquoi parce que quoi qu'il
arrive dimanche matin je vais rigoler
isis excellent je vais être content
parce que le producteur d'émissions et
je suis répond mathieu 1,6 et bah ça
freine c'est que
la vérité je veux pas dessus en middle
pour vous regardez vous regardez pas
mais où je veux une catastrophe pour
qu'on puisse se marrer je veux un énorme
succès
d'accord on se fait chier
voilà je veux où personne ne regarde oui
tous nos maux mais attendez tout le
monde regarde fait de
ccb mieux si on se marre bien parce que
ça a marché même supprimer un chouïa
pour la caméra c'est sympa de faire la
vidéo j'en ai regardé par hasparren a
dit
[Applaudissements]
hiro tient le mât et les
voiles à
la new kids on the site web elle a un
jeu ps3 l'anneau qui
s'avoue
notorious qui dit oui à quoi vous
attendez pas géraldine aussi
j'adore la nuque et
comment ça va
mieux elle aura le sourire non mais ce
qui n'aurait pas mangé de sa belle mort
d'aimé revient à prier pour mathieu bien
sûr la promotion bien sûr que faire que
ça et tu peux nous donner envie de
regarder l'émission désaccord à sa
dernière fois pour la scène s'est passée
pas du tout son truc alors les
humoristes animateurs mais un piètre
vendeur
mais sa famille c'est parce qu'elle vend
des
produits tout je te dis que si je
faisais skate dont et luttons conducteur
alors alors un ancien conducteur ce que
j'ai changé
dit merci il a songé détruit
il a d'ailleurs sauvé devant nous les
missions aléatoires sont là c'est
l'émission qui entrent parfois tentant
par exemple parce que là il ya des gens
qui te regarde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
copine genre va au bidon parce qu'elle
ait des gens qui te regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu as droit alors vanille alors il
faudra déjà les ennemis en termes de
chroniqueurs l'homme est certain mais
déjà tu peux pas démarré on fait chier
merde pas non plus renchérit vous lis le
rendez vous samedi
le vent en poupe
[Applaudissements]
nathalie très banale entre ahmed mestiri
voler la tâche qu'ils connaissent et
quoi nuls a des testicules ils en
vendent une sorte de première à toi tu
vas ses testicules or devant une
tondeuse et dieu
merci allez on y va
alors les emmys samedi soir
[Applaudissements]
vraiment lancement vidéo gag 80
[Rires]
j'adore serre et héroïnes
sont pas traitées vous jacquou depuis
derrière quoi c'est quoi oui vincent oui
oui tranquille sans capitaux dossevi et
j'adore oui tu nous regardes oui c'est
problématique
d'autres solutions maintenant je sais
sur le voit pas on considère qu'on va
dans le mur
d'un programme de leur emplacement aucun
émoi les animaux de la 8 avec le faucon
avec le faucon et labrador
d'amour
[Rires]
bien repassée april
qui va décider si la nouvelle est ce que
tu as envie de voir mathieu n'ont donné
aucun autre enquête faire son émission
oui parce qu'elle a été dans son
émission
est habillée comme ça tu en a rien à
[ __ ] de tpm paix mais parfois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention
bush mais
franchement regard des priorités non
mais sans déconner les deux émissions
mais très vite j'ai demandé de choisir
mais elles sont nées connaît l syncada
c'est la seule map qui vit en petit
déjeuner avec une robe de soirée
mais son ego est alors vas-y de nous
inviter à l'image de nos envies mais il
attendait nous envient samedi et mission
est
de les dire que c'est bien toi remercier
alou merde mettant debout mais la bête
comme étant je ne suis pas content
voilà
[Applaudissements]
allo
en vain
y je viens de voir le conducteur on a on
a énormément de choses à faire
aujourd'hui sur le mien non pas sur le
tien tu vas pas que c'est le mien suis
là aujourd'hui devant la barre touche à
ton plutôt radin rue
c'est devenu mon téléphone ici et
animateur tiens moi j'ai bien eu mon
téléphone ici en
ligne où l'animateur
quatre heures dans le coma alors alors
allez fallu aller vite mais
on a cherché le match qui nous attend on
va tâcher maintenant c'est une constante
chez basique
[Applaudissements]
elle le souffle des trucs de 82 émission
le fou telle est celle où
le pouvoir a fait le toit alors samedi
19 heures 10 et laurent fontaine samedi
19h l'émission de malades avec des
people encore éviter
[Applaudissements]
à
tanger mais quand c'est fini c'est fini
fini tu vas tu vas-y toi
mais coupe de l'info pas quoi c'est
demain 19h10 c'est moi avec l'embrouillé
[Applaudissements]
et
25 ans de métier coco
[Musique]
m il est bon sur courtes sur le
bouchon de glace est ce que préfère une
phrase toulouse pour bah ouais donc
tenir tête à tête des chroniqueurs
franzone l'armée 30 secondes maintenant
qu'il fait pas de cash island
que ça vous fait rire mais
pas drôle
s'étaient pas vues totale saillantes non
ses crachats élan alors demain
disent-ils sur ces 8,2 people de l'info
du scoop mais ça fera ce que tu veux
battre et c'est pas
de l'info du sien sans émission oui
alors demain c'est tout
[Rires]
l'événement c'est sûr c'est vite demain
je leur dise delormeau sur ses pmp
people
arriver non mais attendez vous
applaudissez ça va courir avec c'est un
stagiaire le premier jour au sud est
c'est un animateur aussi policier
attention là on va faire un bond dans
les années 80
[Applaudissements]
bernard est très fort bernard jeu sur
qui tu le vends bien qui veut tout pour
sa gueule mais qui fait jamais rien pour
savoir comment fait-il gilles
super rebelle ouais j'ai pas envie de
savoir
j'adore ce jeu là c'est là on est on est
pas dans ce domaine de compétence et je
vous donne rendez vous ce samedi à 19h10
sur ces 8 ne manquez pas parce que tous
les scoops sont là toute la vérité sur
toutes les infos people de la semaine
vous saurez tout en compagnie de bande
de chroniqueurs très sympa mais bon
[Applaudissements]
tesfran capeletto les shérifs souplesse
et président de la chaîne
oui
je sais pas du tout comment ça peut
coûter
et que comme ça au pied levé
tu penses que ça peut le faire et plus
sécure avec ça et que cette décision là
mais moi je fais de 5 à 6 a brillé
combien vous sûr
comme je sais qu'ils demandent toujours
très cher de l'eure - aujourd'hui le
double de monsieur de lormont
et la réponse du président
de circle 1,9
m
bravo à vous tous sur 5 à 6 c'est ça du
coup qui la lie avec ce que j'ai vu avec
ce que j'ai vu là là pour aider allait
rester chez vous pendant bien longtemps
j'y crois à fond j'y crois à fond il va
être formidable pire toutes façons s'il
vous plaît